this is Harold a monastic the Ritualist  dedicated to the void he harnesses is  awesome power condemned the brings forth  a wave of energy that chains enemies in  place while bolstering heroes shields  penance sacrifices shields providing  health regeneration based on a  percentage of damage dealt by Harrow  while also increasing his fire and  reload rates thurible provides bursts of  energy to Harrow and allies within range  every time he gets the kills amplified  more so for headshots the longer its  active the higher the energy given  covenant protects allies within range  from all damage and status effects for a  short period once ended all protected  allies the additional critical chance  relative to the amount of damage  absorbed Harrow is suffrage and to the  void you intervene Teno